[Musik]
rausgehen nur noch aus triftigem grund
bayern verhängt wegen der korona krise
als erstes bundesland umfassende
ausgangs beschränkungen leere regale im
supermarkt anhalten der hamsterkäufe
sind ein grund warum händler ist nicht
schaffen alle waren schnell wieder
aufzufüllen und machtkampf bei der afg
der parteivorstand will die auflösung
des rechtsextremen flügels um böcke die
nachrichten des tages heute mit barbara
hahlweg guten abend schön dass sie dabei
sind
im kampf gegen das corona virus
schränken immer mehr bundesländer die
bewegungs und versammlungsfreiheit
massiv ein um die menschen zu schützen
auch vor sich selbst sagt bayerns
ministerpräsident söder
zwar hielten sich viele vorbildlich
daran an die regeln aber viele würden es
immer noch nicht ernst nehmen ein
überblick bayern hat den anfang gemacht
das saarland zog am nachmittag nach hier
darf nur noch raus wer triftige gründe
hat die arbeit einkaufen oder
medizinische versorgung hessen und
rheinland-pfalz verbieten versammlungen
von mehr als fünf menschen in baden
württemberg sind nur noch drei personen
zusammen erlaubt in hamburg 6 in allen
diesen bundesländern in niedersachsen
und mecklenburg vorpommern dürfen cafés
und restaurants nicht mehr öffnen ist
wenn glas hat die details weil draußen
allen appellen zum trotz noch immer zu
viele menschen unterwegs sind fühlt er
sich zum handeln gezwungen
markus söder ist der erste
ministerpräsident der heute vor die
presse tritt und ankündigt das
öffentliche leben noch weiter
einzuschränken
vom grundlegenden ausgangs
beschränkungen für den freistaat spricht
er gültig ab 0 uhr
wir fahren das öffentliche leben in
bayern nahezu vollständig herunter ab
morgen gilt noch viel mehr als jetzt
bleiben sie zu hause gehen sie nur in
ausnahmefällen
notwendige einkäufe arzt und apotheken
besucher sind weiter möglich doch
menschenansammlungen sind tabu lange
schlangen am abend an baumärkten denn
auch die sind am morgen zu
auch in restaurants bars und cafés
sitzen geht dann nicht mehr essen nur
noch zum mitnehmen
ähnliche einschränkungen verkündet etwas
später auch winfried kretschmann
restaurant schließungen und auch in
baden württemberg sollen weniger
menschen unterwegs sein
die maßnahme hier ansammlungen von mehr
als drei personen auf öffentlichen
plätzen sind ab morgen verboten familien
ausgenommen
ich bitte sie auch nicht in privaten
räumen irgendwelche treffen und
veranstaltungen zu machen auch wenn wir
das natürlich schwer kontrollieren
können
auch das appelliere ich an sie ihre
verantwortung draußen soll die polizei
die regeln konsequent kontrollieren und
bei verstößen hart durchgreifen ich
meine es ist die richtige maßnahme soll
nur noch die zusammen sein die in einem
haushalt sich von allem fern zu halten
die idiotie weil da oben es sind nicht
nur bayern und baden württemberg sondern
viele bundesländer die ihre regeln im
kampf gegen korona jetzt verschärfen
aber eben nicht alle die maßnahmen
ähnlich und doch unterscheiden sie sich
im detail und so ist die folge ein
föderaler flickenteppich den man
eigentlich vermeiden wollte
felix zimmermann ist war mir aus unserer
rechts redaktion in gebührender distanz
felix sind massive eingriffe in die
persönliche freiheit ist das aus
juristischer sicht vertretbar dass
massive eingriffe in grundrechte
aber es gibt eben auch schutzpflichten
des staates für andere grundrechte zum
beispiel eben das grundrecht auf leben
und körperliche unversehrtheit und der
staat darf nicht tatenlos mit ansehen
wie hunderttausende menschen erkranken
und möglicherweise starben und die
bisherigen maßnahmen ja die waren nicht
besonders erfolgreich der virus
verbreitet sich ungebremst
da es im jetzt handeln sogar rechtlich
geboten würde ich sagen allerdings
wichtig ist immer den grundsatz der
verhältnismäßigkeit zu achten
und da ist es jetzt aus meiner sicht
schon gut darauf zu achten dass zum
beispiel jetzt die häusliche gewalt
nicht an
dicht gedrängt auf engem raum familien
sind und das jetzt zum beispiel in
bayern daran gedacht wurde
das sport weiter möglich ist oder man
spazieren gehen wenn auch eben unter
bestimmten regeln also allein oder zu
zweit
wie sollen diese kontrollen in der
praxis umgesetzt werden muss ich
irgendwas bei mir erfüllen und zu
belegen dass sich zu arbeiten muss oder
muss ich erklären können dass ich
einkaufen muss also bei solchen
kontrollen musste bürger jetzt so heißt
es glaubhaft machen warum er aus
triftigen grund draußen unterwegs ist
dann hilft natürlich eine bescheinigung
des arbeitgebers wenn man einkaufen geht
muss man sich wahrscheinlich die frage
gefallen lassen weil ihr nächster
supermarkt es doch viel näher warum sind
sie hier am anderen ende der stadt
unterwegs
na ja und wenn man dann wirklich jetzt
dagegen verstößt dann drohen bußgelder
bis hin zur freiheitsstrafe aber wie
streng jetzt die behörden hier
durchgreifen das ist bislang noch nicht
absehbar
dankeschön felix zimmermann wir müssen
uns alle umstellen
wieder sind es bayern und andere
bundesländer die hier die regeln und das
tempo bestimmen wir haben es gehört für
alle flickenteppich die frage ist muss
der bund da nicht auf eine einheitliche
lösung drängen theo koll in berlin also
müssen wir uns darauf einstellen dass
die ausgangs beschränkungen bald
bundesweit gelten daher rechtlich kann
und darf der bund keine ausgangssperren
verhängen aber natürlich wird die
kanzlerin am sonntag in ihrer
telefonkonferenz mit den
ministerpräsidenten versuchen eine
bundesweite lösung zu finden denn wir
sehen ja heute schon die absurdität der
unterschiedlichen regelungen in
leverkusen beispielsweise sind ab sofort
zusammenkünfte von zwei oder mehr
menschen im freien untersagt die stadt
berlin hier sieht das alles viel
lockerer wenn wir die erfahrung mit den
schul und kita schließungen zu grunde
legen dann scheint es mir sehr
wahrscheinlich dass am ende die jetzt
vorbrächten länder die anderen mitziehen
werden aber mit entscheiden muss man
sagen kann übrigens jeder von uns
bürgern denn wenn morgen auf den straßen
erkennbar die unvernunft regiert dann
macht das eine ausgangssperre sehr
wahrscheinlich ob nun einheitlich oder
als flickenteppich dankeschön theo koll
und wir gehen ein paar hundert meter
weiter raus ins berliner leben zu
carsten behrendt
freitagabend in der innenstadt kasten
wie viel es los es ist leer hier
verdammt leer so leer wie ich diesen
platz an der gedächtniskirche im herzen
der city west noch nie erlebt habe
normalerweise treffen sich die berliner
hier gehen in die restaurants gehen
shoppen ins kino oder ins theater
jetzt ist alles zu und sie bleiben zu
hause auch tagsüber war die stadt
deutlich leerer als in den vergangenen
tagen noch es gibt natürlich auch
ausweise menschen die sich in parks
treffen zu eng beieinander sitzen oder
vereinzelt auch gastronomen oder
ladenbesitzer die gegen die strengen
schließungs auflagen verstoßen
die berliner polizei hat in der
vergangenheit vergangenen tag 125
strafanzeigen geschrieben und zwar wegen
verstößen gegen das
infektionsschutzgesetz berlins
regierender bürgermeister hat gesagt er
ist kein freund von weiteren aus oder
von ausgeh beschränkungen die gelten
hier nicht in berlin die seien für ihn
nicht das allheilmittel
ja und jetzt sind wir hinter mir den zoo
palastes verweist der lehre gespenstisch
leere kino das steht geschrieben who i
will be back wir kommen zurück die große
frage ist nur wann
dankeschön für diese beschreibung
carsten behrendt auch das
robert-koch-institut hat angesichts des
exponentiellen wachstums der
infektionszahlen erneut eindringlich
daran appelliert abstand zu halten
nach angaben der amerikanischen johns
hopkins universität steigt die zahl
täglich um rund 30 prozent
stand heute 18.30 sind in deutschland 18
1361 menschen infiziert die zahl der
toten hat sich in den vergangenen fünf
tagen von 11 auf 52 erhöht die politik
betont es jeden tag aufs neue und auch
die großen lebensmittelkonzerne
beschwören die versorgung in deutschland
ist sicher dennoch spielen sich in
supermärkten weiterhin skurrile szenen
ab und hamsterkäufe und viele regale
bleiben leer
warum das so ist zeigt anton kuscheln
kein toilettenpapier kein mehl keine
nudeln immer häufiger stehen kunden vor
leeren regalen in der tat gibt es
einzelne engpässe weil toilettenpapier
beispielsweise momentan so stark gekauft
wird wie sonst das ganze jahr nicht und
da sind die fifa strukturen eigentlich
gar nicht für ausgelegt und insofern
gibt es in der tat hierbei engpässe um
die regale wieder auffüllen zu können
bestellen die supermarktketten immer
schneller immer mehr ware die gibt es
zwar aber die logistik kommt mit der
lieferung kaum mehr hinterher
die lkw fahrer sind am anschlag hinzu
kommt dass viele fahrer aus dem ausland
kommen und angst haben angst haben nicht
mehr nach hause zu kommen weil die
grenzen überall dicht gemacht werden
es gibt natürlich die verunsicherungen
gerade bei den mitgliedsunternehmen also
deutschen transportunternehmen die
ausländisches fachpersonal eingestellt
haben weil wir hier auch wieder einen
europäischen flickenteppich haben jedes
europäische mitgliedsland hat für sich
eine individuelle lösung erlassen
deswegen fordert der logistikverbands
das lkw die grenzen in europa passieren
dürfen ohne kontrolliert zu werden nur
so könne die versorgung gesichert werden
weiß auch die zuständige ministerin die
sich heute in einem logistik lager von
aldi über die probleme informiert
beschäftigungslose aus der gastronomie
etwa sollen helfen in der landwirtschaft
und im handel
wir haben viele branchen wo ja arbeit
ausfällt wo menschen auch keine arbeit
haben und keine einkünfte haben gerade
und wir haben viele die nachfragen ob
sie in der landwirtschaft helfen können
wir werden eine plattform über das
wochenende entwickeln um beide seiten
regional zusammenzubringen
natürlich sehen wir gerade eine
verstärkte nachfrage gerade nach
haltbaren lebensmitteln und produkten
aber unsere lieferkette funktioniert
und wenn es temporär zu lücken kommt
können wir die gemeinsam mit allen
schnell und zeitnah schließen die korona
krise sie macht auch kreativ wer in
sachsen bei diesem metzger einkaufen
geht bekommt zum fleisch eine rolle
toilettenpapier dazu und zwar gratis
zwei wichtige meldungen aus der
wirtschaft mehr als 76.000 unternehmen
haben bereits kurzarbeit beantragt das
ist eines der mittel um die folgen der
korona krise für die arbeitnehmer
abzufedern
die bundesagentur für arbeit übernimmt
dann 60 prozent der lohnfortzahlung und
arbeitgeber und gewerkschaften ziehen an
einem strang
es gibt einen neuen tarifvertrag für die
vier millionen beschäftigten der metall
und elektroindustrie
oberstes ziel ist es die arbeitsplätze
zu sichern
deswegen verzichtet die ig metall auf
lohnerhöhungen vereinbart wurden regeln
die krise gemeinsam durchzustehen
eines der ersten hochrisiko gebiete in
deutschland war der kreis heinsberg in
nordrhein westfalen weiterhin gibt es
dort viele fälle aber seit die pandemie
sich deutschlandweit ausgeweitet hat ist
heinsberg aus dem blick geraten
nach dem ausbruch hatten die behörden
dort schnell reagiert strenge maßnahmen
erlassen die erfahrungen gelten viele
als beispiel für das was überall droht
und wie zu reagieren es dort bewerber in
düsseldorf was hören sie aus heinsberg
nun den heinsberg hatte man ja die
schulen direkt nach dem bekanntwerden
des ersten falles geschlossen
seit dreieinhalb wochen liegt dort das
öffentliche leben quasi flach es gibt
dort inzwischen 916 infizierte
dreizehntes das sind vornehmlich sind
ausschließlich menschen hochbetagt mit
vorerkrankungen und man hat die zahl der
infektions betten von 16 auf 100
aufgestockt aber auch das reicht
inzwischen nicht mehr
die patienten müssen in krankenhäusern
außerhalb von heinsberg behandelt werden
es mangelt an personal es mangelt an
schutzausrüstung dort aber es gibt auch
gute nachrichten es gibt inzwischen
genesene 84 und es gibt eine große
solidarität der menschen untereinander
man hilft sich die krise hat ein
zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl
hervorgebracht dann bestimmt doch das
war in der krise zeigen sich fürsorge
und solidarität wären es gehört da sind
fußball profis die mit einer million
euro die initiative week corona gründen
da gibt es neu erwachte
nachbarschaftshilfe und es gibt firmen
die aus der not weil sie im moment keine
aufträge haben eine tugend machen und
ehrenamtlich helfen
johanna kießler die männer in dieser
erfurter firma sorgen für sicherheit
normalerweise bei messen konzerten und
fußball spielen
doch krisen zeiten erfordern
improvisationstalent schon mitarbeiter
gesagt keiner von euch wird auf der
straße stehen kann wird arbeitslos
werden
wir gehen jetzt ruhig wir nutzen die
zeit um uns einfach zu engagieren
menschen zu zeigen solidarität einem
facebook-aufruf später sieht die
auftragslage anders aus statt
rumzusitzen fahren die sicherheitsleute
jetzt kostenlos einkaufen für menschen
die ihr haus derzeit möglichst nicht
verlassen sollten sicherheit auch hier
oberstes gebot
eigentlich darum den schutz für die
älteren oder kranken menschen zu
garantieren
deswegen jetzt hat man schutz auch für
uns noch mal alles desinfiziert
wechselgeld vorbereitet ist hab ich
vorher
perfektion gewartet dass wir jetzt wenn
wir jetzt geld ausgeben in die
stammesmitglieder irgendwas übertragen
insgesamt sechs bestellungen sind es
heute aus dem gesamten eher futter
stadtgebiet sie tun was sie können und
die menschen danken es ihnen
es sind schwierige zeiten für alle die
sicherheitsfirma kann für die auftrags
freie zeit auf kurzarbeitergeld hoffen
sich trotz eigener schwierigkeiten noch
freiwillig für mitmenschen zu engagieren
ein gutes signal in zeiten der krise die
ganze welt kämpft gegen korona in
italien steigt die zahl der todesfälle
weiter deutlich an allein heute kommen
627 dazu auch der iran gehört zu den am
stärksten betroffenen ländern
die zahl der todesfälle ist dort in den
letzten 24 stunden von 1284 auf 1433
gestiegen sagt das
gesundheitsministerium zudem seinen 19
1644 infektionsfälle registriert worden
ein anstieg und 1237 fälle binnen eines
tages jörg brase
so haben sie in iran ihr neujahrsfest
noch nie gefeiert die moscheen sind
geschlossen einzelne beten vor
verschlossenen toren und das
staatsoberhaupt spricht per fernseh
botschaft so nation das volk gehe durch
harte prüfungen sagte ayatollah khamenei
und ruft die menschen auf auch im neuen
jahr dem corona virus sind den us
sanktionen zu trotzen
wenn wir es schaffen unsere eigene
produktion zu steigern und zu entwickeln
können wir unsere wirtschaftsprobleme
beenden und die sanktionen die man gegen
uns verhängt hat werden sich sogar zu
unserem nutzen wenn
die us-sanktionen beklagt irans führung
verstärkten die korona epidemie
desinfektionsmittel masken und viele
medikamente seien knapp zwar arbeiten
krankenhäuser an der belastungsgrenze
doch von panik keine spur es gibt keine
hamsterkäufe
die geschäfte sind gut bestückt auch die
preise sind seit ausbruch der epidemie
nur leicht gestiegen so gelassen
reagiert nur ein volk das seit vielen
jahren an krisen gewöhnt ist zwar
forderte die regierung die menschen auf
über das neujahrsfest auf
familienbesuche zu verzichten
trotzdem machten sich millionen auf die
reise weil man es wohl ahnte werden an
den provinz grenzen verstärkt
gesundheitskontrollen durchgeführt das
iranische volk hat in der not immer
zusammen gestanden so gott will ist
unsere einheit stärker und wir werden
das corona virus besiegen die lage aber
bleibt dramatisch
trotzdem verzichtet die regierung auf
eine ausgangssperre fürchtet den totalen
kollaps der wirtschaft und wohl auch
dass die stimmung noch schlechter wird
als sie es eh schon ist russland gibt
sich betont gelassen in sachen corona
präsident putin selbst braucht nach den
worten seines sprechers keinen test
putin fühle sich immer blendend
doch nun gibt es auch in russland den
ersten todesfall bislang sind im land
253 infektionsfälle offiziell bekannt
experten sagen jedoch die dunkelziffer
ist hoch für begann vor den toren der
russischen hauptstadt wird im eiltempo
gebaut
eine infektion skrynnik mit 5 bis 6 100
betten
angesichts der mindestens zwölf
millionen einwohner moskaus erscheint
das wenig innerhalb eines monats sollen
die bauarbeiten abgeschlossen sein
die chinesen haben dafür zehn tage
gebraucht
juni gibt wir sind keine chinesen das
ist ein großer unterschied wir sind
russen
offiziell gibt es in russland erst sehr
wenig cupid 19 erkrankungen
allerdings sollen die tests und
zuverlässig sein und längst nicht jeder
lungenentzündung patient wird auf das
neue virus getestet
schulen und universitäten bleiben
geschlossen
die moskauer metro mit ihren fünf
millionen passagieren täglich fährt
russland handle widersprüchlich und zu
langsam warnte kabelbrand schon vor
tagen er leitet mehrere kliniken in
moskau vermutlich ist die lage schlimmer
als sie dargestellt wird es ist schwer
zu sagen ob sich daran noch etwas ändern
ließe weil die notwendigen massnahmen zu
lange nicht getroffen wurden
doch von einem virus will sich vladimir
putin seine volksbefragung nicht
verderben lassen
die soll ende april eine
verfassungsänderung legitimieren
damit kann putin zwölf jahre länger im
amt bleiben
so betont der präsident wie hier
anlässlich des jahrestages der krim
annexion dass russland alles im griff
habe und schüttelt weiter hände zurück
nach deutschland 11 millionen kinder und
jugendliche sind derzeit im heim
unterricht eine ziemliche
herausforderung auch für die eltern der
lehrer verband rät eltern sollten nicht
den anspruch haben den normalen
schulunterricht eins zu eins zu hause
fortsetzen zu wollen
sie sollten sich lieber auf die
kernfächer konzentrieren und es müssten
auch nicht vier oder fünf stunden pro
tag sein
heute gibt es ein zdf spezial zur krone
epidemie direkt nach dieser 19 uhr heute
sendungen jederzeit auf dem laufenden
sind sie mit unserem live blog online
auf heute de und in der heute zu einem
ganz anderen thema der afd
bundesvorstand hat beschlossen dass der
sogenannte flügel sich auflösen soll der
gruppierung um gründer bauernhöfe werden
etwa 7000 anhänger zugeordnet seit
vergangener woche wird der flügel vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet er wird als
rechtsextrem eingestuft einige
landesverbände drängt deshalb auf eine
auflösung nicole diekmann hat die
details
turbulent wurde es werden hatte es aus
parteikreisen vorher geheißen man rechne
mit viel streit ausgang ungewiss
entsprechend wortkarg die teilnehmer der
afg vorstandssitzung heute vormittag die
offizielle einstufung des flügels als
rechtsextrem die beobachtung auch seiner
anführer kallwitz und hocke durch den
verfassungsschutz
die angst geht um in der afg besonders
die landesverbände nrw und hamburg
fordern konsequenzen
bei so viel druck auf dem kessel wollte
sich die parteispitze heute morgen nur
zu einem thema äußern
was ich ihnen sagen kann dass ich sehr
froh gemüt in die sitzung hineingehe
denn ich habe vor 20 minuten erfahren
dass er gegen heute aus der partei
ausgeschlossen wurde
der baden-württembergische abgeordnete
wolfgang gedeon war mit schriften
aufgefallen die als antisemitisch gelten
trotzdem steht die afg lange über seinen
ausschluss ob es zufall ist dass der
ausgerechnet jetzt beschlossen wurde wo
der druck hoch ist wie nie kann wohl nur
die partei beantworten
die bemüht sich weiter zu beweisen dass
sie auf dem boden der freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung steht das
ergebnis der vorstandssitzung verkündete
man deshalb gerne
wir haben in der frage der vorwürfe
gegen den flügel beschlossen dass wir
vom flügel erwarten der morgen tagen
wird dass er sich morgen dazu
entschließt den flügel bis zum
dreißigsten vierten komplett aufzulösen
ob sich die mächtigen köpfe des flügels
dagegen stimmen
wie realistisch die auflösung einer
informellen vereinigung ist und wie
ernst die partei überhaupt meint viele
fragen bleiben offen
morgen trifft sich der flügel und auch
das dürfte turbulent werden noch eine
wichtige nachricht für alle rentner sie
werden ab ersten juli spürbar mehr geld
in der tasche haben
sozialminister heil erklärte auch in
ungewissen zeiten stehe die
rentenversicherung für verlässlichkeit
im westen steigen die renten um 3,45
prozent im osten um 4,2 prozent
grundlage für die berechnung ist die
entwicklung der löhne und die sind im
vergangenen jahr wegen der guten
konjunktur gestiegen
auch wenn es noch völlig unklar ist ob
die olympischen sommerspiele in tokio
überhaupt wie geplant stattfinden
die olympische flamme ist schon mal im
land in einem sonderflugzeug aus
griechenland landete sie auf der
hauptinsel honshu
dort entzündeten zwei dreifache
goldmedaillengewinnerin feuer mit einem
staffellauf soll die fackel ab ende märz
von fukushima bis nach tokio getragen
werden und auch die musikwelt passt sich
der krise an statt großer konzerte
gibt's hausmusik für die fans superstar
pink kostet diese privatvorstellung am
klavier
wohnung von youtube nutzt gleich die
gelegenheit um seinen neuen song zu
testen und zahlreiche hollywood größten
singen imagine von john lennon singen
hilft man muss es auch nicht können
sonnenlicht hilft auch allerdings wird
es morgen kühl und im süden schneit und
regnet es im norden dafür sonne
die details zum wetter hat gleich
gunther tiersch wir halten sie den
ganzen abend über die korona krise auf
dem laufenden direkt im anschluss kommt
das zdf spezial um 22 uhr begrüßte
marietta slomka im heute-journal und
hier ist morgen christian sievers drin
alles gute ihn haben sie einen schönen
abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
kondom liebe zuschauer das würde ein
kaltes und windiges wochenende aber es
wird überwiegend die sonne scheint jetzt
kommt polarluft zu uns über skandinavien
strömt sie nach süden anfangs eben mit
diesen regen gebieten die dann teilweise
auch morgen in schnee übergehen und am
sonntag scheint dann überall bei uns in
deutschland die sonne ja heute nacht
haben wir es also mit dieser front zu
tun regen in der mitte deutschlands
zieht langsam weiter nach süden haben
wir anfangs noch die schauer und
gewitter gehabt und morgen früh liegt
die schneefallgrenze sind 600 meter höhe
frostig wird jetzt allerdings nur im
norden bis minus 1 grad sonst bleibt es
frostfrei und tagsüber ja das scheint
die sonne norddeutschland wunderbares
wetter aber es weht ein doch starker
böiger nordostwind dazu der ist richtig
cool und kalt kann man sagen in der
mitte deutschlands wird es dann schon
wolkiger und südlich des mains ist es
stark bewölkt es regnet oder schneit
zeitweise und die schneefallgrenze sinkt
bis zum abend hier vor allen dingen in
bayern und an den alpen auf 4 500 meter
höhe im westen ist es milder
da haben wir dann am oberen temperaturen
12 grad deshalb liegt die
schneefallgrenze höher niederrhein 10
grad sonst aber nur noch zwei bis acht
grad und die aussichten kaltes wetter
muss man sagen am sonntag aber auch in
der neuen woche ist bleibt sonnig und
nachts gibt es frost
ich wünsche mir einen schönen abend und
machen sie's gut